(light piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large-brained,
long the master of fire,
tools and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves,
aware that death is inevitable,
yet, filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from
our shared understanding
of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines,
to exchange insights on who
we are, and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans,
like you.
(light electronic music)
(mid-tempo electronic music)
- So, some of you know my
interests in anthropogeny,
originated from studies in
sialic acid, biology changes,
and human evolution.
And my background as a physician
led me to explore human specific diseases.
So, what, then, am I doing here,
talking about death
awareness and mortality?
In 2005, I lectured at
the University of Arizona,
and ventured beyond my expertise,
of pining about the
evolution of human cognition.
At the lunch that followed,
a local professor sat next to me and said,
"You are all asking the wrong question!"
Danny Brower's point was, perhaps,
we should not be asking
how human minds evolved.
There have been highly-intelligent,
warm-blooded social creatures around
for tens of thousands of years.
Elephants, carver birds,
apes and dolphins.
So, why are we not having to compete
with these other species?
Danny suggested that it's not just
that something unusual happened
during human evolution,
but also, that all these other species
were blocked in progression,
by a cognitive barrier that
only we had broken through.
So, I was really intrigued
by this contrarian view,
and we talked a long time
after everyone was gone.
And I strongly recommended
that he publish.
Seeing nothing in print,
after more than a year,
I followed up with
emails, got no responses,
looked up his phone
number on the Internet,
only to find his obituary.
Danny had died, very suddenly,
of an unusual disease,
called aortic dissection.
I contact his friend, Sean Carroll,
who said Danny had indeed been working
on some novel idea, but never published.
After more than two decades
of exploring anthropogeny,
I could see some real important
potential in Danny's idea,
and I just could not let it die with him.
Fortunately, the editor of
Nature, Philip Campbell,
allowed me to write a letter
about Danny's idea, with
some embellishments.
I thought I had done my duty,
and could leave it to
experts, to follow up.
But a week later,
I got an email from Danny
Brower's widow, Sharon,
thanking me for writing the letter,
told me that Danny has started a book,
and asked if I would like to read it.
Looking at his draft, I
realized that his thinking
had progressed very much
in the way mine had,
and we had come to very similar
conclusions, independently.
But, there were great challenges
in completing this book.
First, one author was dead.
(crowd laughing)
And the other wanted to
preserve the original intent
and prose.
Second, I really had no time
to do full justice to it,
because of my lack of expertise,
and also, lack of time.
And last, but not least,
who would care about a book
by a dead insect geneticist,
and a living physician-scientist,
who claim to have
explained the human mind?
(crowd laughing)
So, I sat on this for a while,
but, fortunately, a friend
of mine, Abraham Verghese,
an author, put me in touch
with his agent, Mary Evans,
who saw the potential in the book,
and contacted Cary
Goldstein of Twelve Books,
to help me with it.
And so, I went on.
Strike four, was I wouldn't
talk about a Superstorm Sandy.
Strike five, was poor
follow-through on my part,
because of lack of
expertise, and lack of time.
(crowd laughing)
And last, but not least, was a book title
that the publisher insisted
on, which was Denial.
So, for a while, I thought that this
was a hackneyed, old phrase,
that had so many meanings,
that it didn't really
say what I wanted to say.
And in fact, if you looked on Amazon,
you would find not only
the famous, important book,
related to this topic, Denial of Death,
but numerous books with
the word denial in them.
(crowd laughing)
The more I thought about it,
I'd realize that, actually,
the publisher and agent
were right.
All these books are talking,
really, about various versions
of the same phenomenon,
the human penchant for denying reality.
And, in fact, as you read more,
I found other books by
many famous authors,
all of which, are on different topics,
but all contain pieces of the same story,
a human ability to ignore reality.
Let me give you some practical examples.
As a physician, I am
acutely aware of the fact
that lack of exercise,
unhealthy diet, tobacco use,
ignoring obesity, high
blood pressure, sleep apnea,
poor hygiene, and excessive
red meat are bad for you.
But, I'm not gonna ask for
a show of hands, because...
(crowd laughing)
Physicians, like myself,
are equally guilty.
Then, we have massive denial
of scientific reality.
Biological evolution, climate
change, magical cures,
vaccines don't work, worse,
still, they cause autism,
despite of being
debunked, UFOs, of course,
weird cancer risks, not real ones,
and here, in San Diego,
fluoride in the waters,
a Communist plot.
(crowd laughing)
And then, there are many
examples of societal denial
of practical reality.
National debt, each of
you owes 150,000 dollars.
Health care costs, end of
life costs, covert racism,
population growth, and
insistence on rebuilding,
in exactly the places where
the worth earthquakes, floods,
and hurricanes have occured.
And then, of course, the
examples of political distortion
of reality.
(crowd laughing)
I'm not gonna read this slide.
You know what I'm talking about.
(crowd laughing)
But, to be fair, there
are plenty of examples
of distortion of reality,
at the other end of
the political spectrum.
I think Calvin puts it well to Hobbes.
"It's not denial.
"I'm just very selective
about the reality I accept."
(crowd laughing)
So, after writing the book,
I had much difficulty,
finding a single word, or phrase,
that encompasses phenomenons,
and when to use the phrase
identified in the dictionary,
reality denial,
which I'm defining as some kind of
subconscious defense mechanism,
characterized by refusal to acknowledge,
or rationalization of
unwanted, or unpleasant facts,
realities, thoughts, or feelings.
Now, so, I think we have
to add reality denial
to the long list of
unusual and exaggerated
cognitive features of humans,
some of which, are listed here.
But, for most of these other features,
we can think of good reasons
why they might have evolved,
in terms of benefiting humans.
But, at the reality
denial, there's a mystery.
Excessive reality denial are
the kind that humans practice,
should be an evolutionary maladaptation.
Excessive reality denial should result
in excessive risk taking
in the individuals
who have the genetic ability to do that,
should disappear.
(crowd laughing)
So, how, and why, did
excessive reality denial
risk taking evolve in humans?
And what benefits outweigh
those negative consequences?
So now, this brings me another
extension of Danny's idea,
that the independent
evolution of self-awareness,
in the very same intelligent creatures
that we've discussed before,
although, lots of arguments
about the techniques
used in the real conclusions,
it's reasonably clear that chimpanzees,
and perhaps, elephants,
dolphins and magpies,
can recognize themselves in the mirror,
and have some kind of sense of self.
It's hard to define exactly what it is.
But, they certainly do have this.
So, are animals and birds with
awareness of their own self,
also aware of the self-awareness
of others of their own kind?
I asked myself that question,
and did some reading,
and realized I was
thinking about something
that's been well-studied,
called theory of mind,
the ability to attribute
mental beliefs, desires,
intentions, and perspectives, to oneself,
and to others, and to
understand that others, also,
have beliefs, desires,
intentions, and perspectives,
that are similar, or
different, from one's own.
There are many other related terms,
intentionality, et cetera,
that I won't go through.
But, they are overlapping terms.
After reading further, I
realized there's a continuum
in the cognitive development
of theory of mind,
and intentionality.
A two year old human
passes the mirror test.
A three-to-four year old human
has a more rudimentary
theory of mind, that emerges.
A five year old human has
a full theory of mind,
and can tell excellent lies.
(crowd laughing)
But, adult humans have
something that I might call
extended theory of mind, or
multi-order intentionality.
Their ability to do what
we are doing right now.
You're reading my mind,
I'm reading your mind,
and there are a hundred people,
or several hundred people,
across the world, on the live Internet,
watching and thinking of what
you're thinking, or perhaps,
something different.
And with the Internet, of course,
we can have millions of minds
melted across the world,
at the same time.
So, the question, and this
is, of course, a continuum,
the question arises, why is
this extended theory of mind
so well developed in adult humans,
and apparently, not in other species?
So, here's my expansion of Danny's idea.
I suggest that there was a
psychological evolution barrier
that held back all these
other intelligent species,
at about this point in the
evolution of theory of mind.
What might that barrier be?
We can now come back to the
theme of this symposium,
and suggest there's also a continuum
in the awareness of death risk,
and understanding of personal mortality.
I may not have my numbers exactly correct,
but, seems to me that you first
have an automated reaction
to death risk, which, as Joe pointed out,
many species, or all species should have.
Some kind of awareness of death risk.
And if some kind of self-awareness
was enhanced at that time,
you would, maybe, become
aware of the death
of another individual.
But, if I substitute
crows for magpies here,
it's the very same animal birds,
and birds the seem to evolve
some kind of awareness
of death we heard about
earlier in the symposium,
that seems right on the
cusp of what humans have.
And yet, just short of it.
So, the operative word
here, is mortality salience.
Conscious understanding and realization
of one's personal mortality.
So, if we go down this continuum, well,
death anxiety may require
extended theory of mind.
Truly understanding the
death of another individual
would result in
understanding the mortality
of other individuals.
And this conscious
awareness would exaggerate
the systems we've heard about,
that extensive, and
not just actual events,
but even thinking about it,
at the level of
consciousness, as Joe said.
Such individuals would then have reduction
in reproductive fitness.
Evolution doesn't care if you survive.
Evolution cares if you reproduce.
And I suspect that those individuals
who first ran into this barrier,
and maybe it happened many
times, in many species,
had reduction in reproductive fitness,
and could not transmit their genotype.
So then, the emergence of
extended theory of mind
would result in awareness of mortality,
and again, a failure to fix
the genotype in two species.
We've already said that reality
denial should be negative,
so, what of these two
unusual, cognitive features
emerged in the same
minds, at the same time,
a rare, negative, double-negative,
which could result sufficient
tolerance of death anxiety,
to establish the combination of species.
Thus, perhaps, two rare
evolutionary maladpatations,
or negatives, could
have coincided to allow
this mind over reality transition.
I have a much more extended view of this,
that we don't have time to discuss.
(crowd laughing)
I need to talk to the experts to it,
before I go any further with that.
But, "Any theory that makes progress,
"is bound to be initially
counterintuitive."
So, I'd like to suggest
that this hypothetical
singular phase in human evolution,
which mortality salience and
maladaptive death anxiety
were triggered by acquiring
extended theory of mind,
which result in an understanding
of personal mortality.
But then, one time only,
were stabilized by
simultaneous acquisition
of general reality
denial, in the same minds.
I remember asking Danny, there couldn't be
a death denial module.
But, he came to the
same conclusion I have.
We just deny anything we don't like.
(crowd laughing)
So, there are other consequences.
After-life myths,
superstitions, religiosity,
self-deception,
over-confidence, risk-taking,
and last, but not least,
the optimism bias.
Humans are well known to
be irrationally optimistic.
Many studies have shown
this, even in fMRI studies.
And evolutionary modeling...
(crowd laughing)
Shows that reacting, in
an overconfident manner,
can have fitness benefits,
as long as the contested resources
are sufficiently large, compared
to the cost of competition.
Now, if you combine overconfidence
with extended theory of
mind, you got big success.
Of course, here's a case, I believe,
of initially successful, but eventually,
fatal case of reality denial.
So, how important is reality denial?
Let's do a thought
experiment, and delete it.
Well, some other features of humans,
would condemn the partially eliminated,
but let's not dim theory of
mind, and eliminate that.
And you find that most of these unusual,
exaggerative cognitive features of humans,
while they could still be
present, would be greatly dimmed.
So, I suggested this combination
could give you this transition,
which is consistent so
far, with all-known facts,
compatible with the other theories,
not negated by currently-known facts,
but is not not directly testable
by experimental reproduction,
or directly falsifiable by
experimental approaches.
Now, "The great tragedy of science
"is the slaying of a beautiful hypothesis
"by an ugly fact."
(crowd laughing)
And I've been searching for that fact,
to destroy this hypothesis.
If you can find it, let me know.
But, it can't just be, I don't like it.
(crowd laughing)
So, when did this occur in
human evolution, finally?
We know that about two million years ago,
our ancestors from Africa,
some stayed behind,
and some spread all across the old world,
to give rise to neanderthals
and many other species.
And this went down for
almost two millions years,
leaving behind many
species and subspecies.
But, the types of things
that you might think
might be related to theory of mind,
reality denial leaves no
signal that I could think of.
But, symbolic art, complex tool making,
personal ornamentation,
burials with added materials,
all occur around 100-to-200,000 years ago.
Again, the experts would be
much more precise than I am.
This happens to be about the time
that the human migration
and the peopling of the world occurred,
in which species evolved in Africa,
and then gradually
spread across the world,
and essentially took over the planet.
And we are now, unlike
most of the subspecies,
where there are multiple species,
we are the lone survivors and
the masters of the planet.
So, while we can't be
sure, I'd like to speculate
that the evolution of
anatomically-modern humans,
into behaviorally modern humans,
which is seen in the archeological record,
although it's quite incomplete,
may have, at least, partly
involved this transition.
So, it so happens this theory can provide
a unifying explanation,
for several unusual
exaggerated features of humans,
such as theory of mind, which
is beneficial for many things,
reality denial, strong
tendency to self-deception
and false beliefs,
overarching optimism bias,
risk-taking behavior,
recent emergence, perhaps,
as the dominant species, and
replacement of everybody else.
Remember, this would have
to have a genetic basis.
There are some examples
of supporting evidence
I don't have time to talk about.
And issues arising, and future directions,
I don't have time to talk about, but...
(crowd laughing)
I would point out that
some of the brain regions
involved in optimism
bias, anxiety and so on,
are related to some of these things.
So, finally, let me close, by
coming back to Danny Brower.
From Danny Brower's 2007 draft manuscript,
"We are polluting the earth
and changing the climate
"in ways that we can't predict,
and likely at some point,
"can't easily reverse.
"If we're so smart, why do
we continue to sow the seeds
"for our eventual destruction?
"Perhaps, because we
are saddled with a brain
"that is designed by selection
"to cope with the
ultimate disaster, death,
"by denying that it will occur,
"and so we treat other impending disasters
"by denying that they will ever happen.
"Indeed, it it is arguable
"that we are destined to
destroy ourselves as a species."
2007.
You don't have to listen
to climate scientists,
just look at the HSBC banks projection
for what they're gonna run into,
in terms of extreme weather events.
Personally, I think this is a case
where legitimate fear
mongering is appropriate.
It's global and local climate destruction,
not just climate change,
affecting you and everybody
else that you know
in your backyard.
Again, this quote I found
in Danny's manuscript,
"A man who carries a cat by the tail
"learns something he can
never learn in any other way."
(crowd laughing)
We have caught the
climate tiger by the tail,
and we better let go soon.
Finally, from Danny's manuscript here,
a lot of cartoons I couldn't
reproduce in the book,
for copyright reasons, but
I'm just showing one of them.
Dr. Dutz.
"The bad news is you've
got advanced-stage humans.
"The good news is they've
just about run their course
"and you should be on the mend soon."
(crowd laughing)
So, that, I'd like to close with the idea
that two, rare evolution maladaptions,
this is just a theory for discussion,
might have coincided to allow
the mind over reality transition.
Thank you.
(crowd applauding)
- In the 1860s or so,
a Scottish essayist, and I'm
very fond of, Alexander Smith,
wrote, "It is our knowledge
that we have to die
"that makes us human."
And, couple of decades later,
William James, in the 1890s,
he'd called death "the worm at the core
"of the human experience."
And then, if we fast
forward a couple of decades,
almost a century after that, in the 1970s,
the cultural anthropologist,
Ernest Becker,
he won a Pulitzer Prize for
his book, The Denial of Death,
in which he basically elaborated
on that basic idea, it is our
knowledge that we have to die,
that makes us human.
And he did so, by trying
to frame these ideas,
in both an evolutionary,
as well as an existential,
psychodynamic fashion.
And what Becker does,
even though this may sound a tad dated,
given some of the ideas
that we've already been exposed to today,
is to just start with, I think,
the relatively simple
Darwinian assumption,
that people are very similar
to all other forms of life,
in that we're biologically
predisposed to survive,
both in an interest of self-preservation,
as well as reproducing, and
extending our chance overtime.
On the other hand, Darwin
noticed, very early on,
that there's lots of ways,
over billions of years of evolution,
that different forms of
life have accomplished,
that most arduous task
of persisting overtime,
so everything from the turtle shells,
to the eagle's eyesight,
and it raises the question
of what is it,
that is responsible for
our fantastic success?
And the answer is there's lots of things,
of both physical and psychological,
including our relatively-large forebrain,
that gives us the capacity
to think abstractly,
and symbolically, to
the point Becker notes
that only human beings,
as far as we can tell,
can imagine something
that doesn't yet exist,
and then, have the audacity
to take our dreams,
and render them into reality.
Some of you have probably
seen a few head shakes.
I know it's late in the day.
Who's seen da Vinci's
drawings of helicopters
in the 1500s?
And when he did that, people
said, wow, that's crazy.
And yet, today, we are
routinely transported
by what was originally denounced
as the doodlings of a madman.
And so, abstract, symbolic thought,
has certainly served us very well,
and I like how Otto Rank, one
of Freud's disciples, put it,
when he said that "Only human
beings make the unreal real."
What Becker then does, though,
is to move back in time,
a couple of decades,
and to think about this idea in light
of the Danish existential
philosopher, Soren Kierkegaard,
and it was Kierkegaard who pointed out,
that human beings are so smart,
that we come to realize that we exist,
self-awareness, complex theory of mind.
The way that Kierkegaard put it,
it takes a ridiculously-sophisticated,
cognitive apparatus,
to render yourself, the object,
of your own subjective inquiry.
And what Kierkegaard did,
in a little book called
Fear and Trembling,
that I always recommend you buy
for your in-laws' coffee
table, as a holiday gift,
what Kierkegaard said,
was that there are emotional ramifications
of being explicitly self-aware.
And he described them as being
both awesome and dreadful.
Kierkegaard said, you know
what, it's really great
to be self-aware, and to be alive.
Who's ever had one of those magic moments,
you wake up on a
beautiful day, like today.
You didn't win a Nobel Prize,
or you didn't win a great fortune,
and yet, you're just
sublimely appreciative
of the fact that you're alive.
Everybody does look pretty happy today.
(crowd laughing)
I grew up in New Jersey.
So, it's a little dicier.
But, I think, for the most
part, we all understand,
just the sublime and
spontaneous exuberance
that comes from being alive,
and knowing that we're here.
On the other hand, Kierkegaard
turns right around,
and he says, yeah, but it's
also dreadful to be alive,
and to know it, because less
GB, either a small child,
or neurologically impaired,
if you're smart enough
to know that you're here,
you're also smart enough to know that,
like all living things,
your life is a finite duration.
Moreover, you're smart enough to realize
that your life could end in any time,
for reasons that you could
never anticipate, or control.
And that, from a purely
biological perspective,
you're a breathing piece
of defecating meat,
that is no more fundamentally
significant, or enduring,
than a lizard, or a potato.
And, what Becker argued,
is that the explicit awareness
of the reality of the human condition,
we will all someday die.
We can die at any time.
We're breathing pieces of
meat, cold cuts with attitudes.
We're Spam.
We're the plan boat, if you've got no can,
would literally debilitate
us with paralyzing,
existential terror.
And what Becker proposed,
is that human beings
manage the terror that is engendered
by the awareness of their mortality,
by embedding ourselves,
in what the anthropologists call culture,
humanly-constructed beliefs
about the nature of reality,
that we share with our
fellow human beings,
that give us a sense
that life have meaning,
and that we have value.
And what Becker points
out, as an anthropologist,
is that all cultures have
stories, or accounts,
of the origin of the universe.
All cultures have prescriptions
for how we ought behave
while we're here.
All cultures offer hope of
immortality, either literally,
through the heavens,
souls, and afterlives,
of the world's great religions,
or symbolically, through the belief
that while you may not be here,
and I may not be here forever,
we're comforted by the prospect
that some manifestation of our existence
will persist over time,
perhaps, from having children,
perhaps, from amassing great fortunes,
perhaps, from producing great
works of art and science.
Moreover, what culture does for us,
is to give us, each, social roles,
with associated standards of conduct,
that if we meet, or exceed them,
allow us to think that
we're persons of value,
in a world of meaning.
And when we do think
that way about ourselves,
Becker called that self-esteem.
His argument is that because
our beliefs about the world,
and because self-esteem are so important,
that whether we're aware of it, or not,
most of our behavior from day to day,
is motivated in the service
of maintaining those beliefs.
Alright, two questions.
One question is, so what?
And the other is question,
is any of this true?
The so what question, in our world,
is generally framed in
transit conceptual power,
what is it that you could understand,
if you momentarily accept the
voracity of Becker's claims,
that it might be less easy
to understand otherwise,
and then, the second question is,
well is there any evidence,
in support of these views?
What we did, and when I say we,
I mean, my buddies Jeff Greenberg,
now, at the University of Arizona,
and Tom Pyszczynski, now at
the University of Colorado,
at Colorado Springs.
We developed a very simple
laboratory paradigm.
It's called the mortality
salience paradigm,
and the logic, I think,
is disarmingly simple.
We just said, alright, if
these ideas are correct,
if our beliefs about
reality serve to mitigate
death anxiety, well, let's
bring people into the lab,
and let's remind them
that they're going to die.
And in controlled conditions,
let's remind them,
it's not as glorious as it sounds,
let's remind them, in
controlled conditions,
of something unpleasant, but not fatal.
For students, think about your next exam.
For regular people, think
about going to the dentist,
and needing a root canal
without anesthesia.
Think about being in a car crash,
and having a limb amputated.
All unpleasant, but
not particularly fatal.
Alright, in our typical paradigm,
we bury in a bunch of personality scales,
two open-ended questions,
"Please briefly describe the emotions
"that the thought of your
own death arouse in you,"
and "Jot down, as specifically as you can,
"what you think will happen
to you as you physically die."
Alright, we do this in
a lot of ways, though.
Sometimes, we go outside the lab,
and we stop people, either in
front of the funeral parlor,
or a hundred meters to either side,
thinking that when you're in
front of a funeral parlor,
death may be on your mind,
even if you don't know it.
And then, the most subtle paradigm,
we call it subliminal death primes.
If you come to my office at Skidmore,
you can your email, and
while you're doing that,
we'll flash the word
death for 28 milliseconds,
so fast, that you don't know
that you have been exposed
to that rather unwelcome stimulus.
Alright, so, that's what we do.
All of these methods
produce the same outcomes.
And so, let's briefly talk about
some of the areas of inquiry.
A lot of them, Ajit mentioned
earlier, in his fine talk.
Alright, so what do we know,
based on almost 40 years of research?
Our original interest
was trying to understand
why people can't get
along with other people,
who don't share their beliefs
about the nature of reality.
And what Ernest Becker said
in a book called Escape from Evil,
is that other people pose
an existential challenge
to our belief systems,
because if you accept an
alternative conception of reality,
you do so, by undermining the confidence
with which you subscribe to your own.
And when you do that,
you undermine the beliefs
that serve to minimize your anxiety.
And what he proposed,
is that when we run into
people who are different,
the first thing we do is to
denigrate or belittle them.
While we do that, we
simultaneously try to get them
to get rid of their ideas,
and adopt ours instead.
And if that doesn't work,
just kill those people,
thus proving that my god
is better than your god,
and we will kick your ass to prove it.
Now, in support of that view,
what we know in several hundred studies,
conducted all over the world,
by our people and independent researchers,
is, for example, Christians
reminded of their mortality,
they like fellow Christians a lot more,
and they hate Jewish people.
If you go to Israel,
and remind Jewish people
of their mortality,
they love Jewish people,
and they hate Arabs and Christians.
Germans reminded of their mortality
sit closer to fellow Germans,
and they sit further away from people
who look like Turkish immigrants.
Iranians reminded of their mortality,
become more supportive of suicide bombers,
and more willing to become
a suicide bomber themselves.
In America, as you know,
we're very practical.
We're not about to blow ourselves up,
but we're happy to blow up other people.
When we remind Americans
of their mortality,
they become more supportive
of the preemptive use
of biological, nuclear,
and chemical weapons,
against countries who pose
no direct threat to us.
Another area of inquiry,
for us, that's not funny,
has been understanding
how existential anxieties
have a radical effect on
political preferences.
Max Weber, the German sociologist
at the beginning of the 20th century,
coined the term charismatic leader.
He said that in times
of historical upheaval,
and existential anxieties
are apt to be aroused,
that we often embrace a certain kind
of seemingly larger than life leader,
who he called charismatic.
And he said that, very often,
these are people who believe to be,
either divinely ordained,
or self-appointed,
in order to rid the world of evil.
And we got interested in this,
in the aftermath of September 11th, 2001.
Old-timers may remember
that in a three-week period,
President George W. Bush
went from the least liked,
to the most liked president
in American history.
We did a lot of studies,
leading up to the 2004 election,
where we showed that Americans
preferred Senator John Kerry
to President Bush, in
a benign state of mind.
However, when they were reminded
of their mortality first,
they liked President Bush a whole lot more
than Senator Kerry.
Ditto, on this election.
This summer, we found in several studies,
that our respondents
preferred Secretary Clinton
to now-President Trump,
when they were in a
psychologically-benign state of mind.
However, when they were reminded
of their mortality first,
their affection and support
for the President Trump
increased, and they now liked him,
more than they did Secretary Clinton.
Alright, let's keep going,
and let's see how death
anxiety fosters an alienation
from nature, and contempt
for the environment.
John Locke, in the 1890s,
in The Second Treatise on Government,
pointed out that anything that's natural,
it is of finite duration.
And, of course, that's what we chafe at,
and that may have been
the psychological impetus
for the construction of the supernatural.
And to the extent, that's true.
When death is on our mind, we
should chafe at the prospect
that we're animals,
and we should be uncomfortable in nature.
And that's exactly what we find.
People, who are reminded
of their mortality,
that take issue with claims
that humans are animals.
They have more negative
attitudes towards animals,
and think it's okay to kill them,
for reasons other than
food, and medical research.
People reminded of their mortality,
become more uncomfortable,
when they're out in nature.
And people reminded of their mortality,
become more willing to greedily exploit
non-renewable natural resources.
And, of course, we can't
talk about the plundering
of the environment, without
a concurrent consideration
of our seemingly insatiable
desire, for money and stuff.
I like how Big Daddy in Cat
on a Hot Tin Roof put it,
when he said, "The human
animal is a beast that dies,
"and if he's got money, he
buys, and buys, and buys,
"and I think the reason he buys
everything that he can buy,
"is that, in the back of his mind,
"he has the crazy hope
that one of his purchases
"will be life ever-lasting."
And research shows that Big
Daddy's right on the money.
People reminded of their mortality,
say that they have higher
fiscal aspirations.
And they say it would take more money,
before they would perceive
themselves as wealthy.
People reminded of their
mortality want more stuff.
Not just any stuff, they want
high-status luxury items,
like a Lexus, and a Rolex.
When people are reminded
of their mortality,
and you ask 'em to draw pictures of money,
they draw bigger pictures,
as if money looms larger,
when death is on their mind.
And just giving people
money to count, not to keep,
just counting money,
reduces death anxiety.
If you like cookies, and
you're reminded of death,
you eat more cookies.
If you smoke cigarettes, and
you're reminded of death,
you smoke more cigarettes.
If you drink alcohol, and
you're reminded of death,
you drink more alcohol.
(stammers) Well, so,
Thomas Hardy, one of my
favorite novelists, said,
"If a way to the better there be,
"it comes from taking a
close look at the worst."
And just to follow up
on some of the things
that Ajit talked about
at the end of his talk,
I would argue that
malignant manifestations
of death anxiety,
surely, do not bring out the best in us.
They seem to turn us into
hateful, warmongering,
proto-fascist, plundering the planet,
in our insatiable quest for dollars,
and draws in a television, alcohol, drug,
Facebook, Twitter-induced stupor.
And...
(crowd laughing)
And Danny Brower might be right, in 2007,
when he said that, wow, an ironic effect,
or to deny death, may be that
we are the first form of life
to have the ignominious distinction
of being responsible for our extinction.
Alright, having said that, though,
let me close on a more positive note,
and just point out,
(crowd laughing)
usually, I stop now, and
I go, thank you very much.
On a more positive note, though,
human beings, we have a good
track record, historically,
of extricating ourselves
from some very difficult circumstances,
once we understand what underlies them.
In the middle ages, when people
were dropping like flies,
from the plague,
when we thought that it
was caused by evil spirits,
we really didn't get anywhere.
On the other hand, when we
realized that it was bacteria,
then, we were able to develop penicillin,
and that led to modern medicine.
Similarly, what I would like to think,
even if this appears naively optimistic,
is that if we could
collectively come to recognize
the incredible problems,
that excessive death denial has produced,
then, maybe, we can
also collectively deploy
our remarkable creativity, and ingenuity,
in order to nudge our
species into a more benign,
or maybe, even more benevolent direction.
I like how Camus put it,
"Come to terms with death.
"Thereafter, anything is possible."
Maybe an overstatement,
but no harm in using this as
a standard to approximate.
Thank you very much.
(crowd applauding)
- And such, you said,
we thought we should discuss
this issue of suicide
at this meeting, because it is something,
which is almost certainly,
had a major bearing on
history of our own species.
I've shown the panel from
a late Roman ivory casket,
which is in the British Museum.
You'll see, it shows two very
different examples of humans,
who brought death on
themselves deliberately.
Jesus, who had no desire to stop living,
but who believed his death
would benefit all mankind.
And then, Judas, who had no
thought of benefiting others,
(stammers) but assumed that his own death
would at least put an end to
his own intolerable guilt.
Suicide used to be called self-murder.
It may seem hard to associate,
harsher to say, to associate
suicide with murder.
But, if we're looking
for the evolutionary
antecedents of suicide,
I think this does, in fact,
get us off on the right foot.
Humans have always been murderers.
First, of course,
they've been killers
of other living beings.
First, of course, they were
killers of animal prey,
for food, and everybody in the community
would've been involved directly, in that.
But, they were also killers
of other human beings.
Not everyone would've
had firsthand experience
of assassination.
But, everyone would've known
about it, and talked about it,
and note, celebrated it.
And then, the idea dawned.
Here's how psychiatrist
Erwin Stengel has put it.
"At some stage of evolution,
man must have discovered,
"that he can kill not only
animals and fellow-men,
"but also himself.
"It can be assumed that
life has never since
"been the same for him."
But, I think it wasn't
so much the discovery,
that he can kill himself,
that would've changed things.
It was the discovery
of what killing himself
would've amounted to,
that it would've amounted to
removing himself from the world.
A human could choose not to be.
That's why non-human
animals don't, and can't,
commit suicide.
At any rate, even if
they do kill themselves,
as perhaps, these whales did,
we shouldn't call it suicide.
Though, that BBC headline
clearly did suggest we might.
The whales can't have been choosing death,
because, so far, as we know,
they haven't discovered what death means.
But, humans, of course, have done.
Humans can choose death,
knowing pretty well what it'll
mean for them personally.
Now, I think Stengel's right to say,
that this discovery has
been transformative.
But, we still have to ask,
transformative in just what ways?
And if we're thinking
about human evolution,
the question must be,
what effects, good or bad,
did this discovery have
on biological survival?
Other kinds of killing
can clearly be adaptive.
It's easier to explain the
survival advantages of hunting.
It's not difficult to explain
the advantages of war,
or homicide.
But, common sense would seem
to say that self-killing
must be the ultimately
disadvantageous act,
a sure path to genetic oblivion.
Yes, the stark fact is,
that suicide is alarmingly
common, right across the world.
Someone in the United States
kills themselves every 12 minutes.
That's 120 a day.
Across the world, more
people die from suicide,
than all wars, and homicides, combined.
We surely have to ask, then,
is suicide biologically
adaptive after all?
Well, the answer's not going to be simple.
As I implied with my first slide,
I think we need to distinguish
two rather different kinds of suicide.
And we can call them as their kind did,
altruistic suicide and egoistic suicide.
And I want to suggest a correspond
to two rather different
conceptions of what death does.
The first, and simplest conception,
is that death results in the
annihilation of the body.
The dead person is no longer an actor
in the physical, or social world.
And corresponding to this,
when people choose to bring
about their own death,
they're, maybe, trying to
make things better for others,
by giving up their own bodily presence.
Jesus died on the cross,
in the hope of becoming
the savior of all mankind.
Or, for a more straightforward
example, Captain Oates,
stumbled out to die in the snow,
in the hope of relieving the burden
for the remaining members
of Scott's polar expedition.
Altruistic suicide, we can call that.
But, could this kind
of suicide be adaptive?
It certainly could be,
provided it benefits the
subject's kin, or social group.
In fact, it's possible,
that a propensity for altruistic suicide,
has been selected in humans,
in rather the same way
that something like it has been selected
in the social instance.
So, maybe, humans are
genetically predisposed,
like ants or bees, to
sacrifice themselves,
for the common good,
in times of famine, or plague, or war,
or simply, when they become too old
and decrepit to carry on.
But now, let's look at
another kind of suicide,
perhaps, corresponding
to a second conception
of what death does.
It says that death results in
the annihilation of the mind.
The dead person is no longer
a thinker, or a feeler.
In correspondence to this conception,
when people kill themselves,
they're, maybe, trying to make
things better for themselves,
by giving up on their
own conscious presence.
Judas Iscariot sought conscious oblivion,
because he could not live with
his internal sense of shame.
This young couple could not bear the pain
of being forbidden by
their families, to marry.
This is egoistic suicide.
And this, in many ways,
they're absolute opposite
of altruistic suicide.
Far from hoping to benefit others,
these self-killers are
motivated, primarily,
by self interest.
They either don't care
about the effect on others,
or, sometimes, they even
intend some kind of vengeance.
And whether they intend it, or not,
the effects on family and
friends are often devastating.
Now, here's the problem from
an evolutionary point of view.
The fact is, that 90 percent
of suicides are egotistical.
The World Federation of
Mental Health, for example,
reports that the most common
situations, or life events,
that might cause suicidal thoughts,
that don't have to do
with helping other people,
that grief, sexual abuse,
financial problems, remorse,
rejection, relationship
breakup, and unemployment.
And anthropologist, Charles MacDonald,
having surveyed suicide across
the whole world, concludes,
"A cross-cultural comparison
shows that grief over,
"and conflict between
closely related people,
"together with sheer
physical pain and discomfort,
"cause, or promote suicide
"more often than any other circumstances.
"The suicide simply
wants to stop hurting."
What their egoistic
suicide wants to achieve,
is basically self-euthanasia.
Well, could this be adaptive?
Though, how could it possibly be?
Most egoistical suicides are young.
Across the world,
it's the second-most
common cause of death,
amongst teenagers.
If they've not died by their own hand,
this couple hadn't died by their own hand,
they would, almost certainly,
have got over the hurt,
and gone on to make a
success of their lives.
Egoistic suicides,
will end not only their
own biological fitness,
but those other related individuals, too.
So, what's going on?
Why do these tragic deaths
happen so frequently?
I think the answer's all too obvious.
Humans, and humans alone,
understand that by killing themselves,
they can, indeed, stop the hurting.
So, there must be circumstances,
when they may well look on
suicide as a rational act.
They feel sad, or jealous, or unloved,
or inadequate, or whatever.
These are feelings that
death will make go away.
Nothing hurts less than being dead.
In Hamlet's (stammers)
sorry, that once more,
as the poetry of suicide,
continue to reminds us,
this solution to the hurting
may not only be rational,
it must, often be, relatively easy.
In Hamlet's notorious soliloquy,
"Who would bear the
whips and scorns of time,
"The oppressor's wrong,
the proud man's contumely,
"The pangs of despised
love, the law's delay,
"When he himself might his quietus make
"With a bare bodkin?"
A dagger.
As some would recognize is,
there's an unfortunate
truth about being human,
probably more true of humans,
than any other animal,
and it is that hurting is part of life.
The part of Ceasuri
Provezi, said it explicitly,
everyone, every human, has
a good reason for suicide.
The philosopher, Wittgenstein,
once told a friend,
that all his life, there
had hardly been a day,
in which he hadn't thought
suicide a possibility.
More typically, among today's
American high school students,
60 percent say they've
considered killing themselves.
14 percent have thought
about it seriously,
in the last year.
And five percent have attempted it.
That's more than one
million students a year.
Susan Sontag has written,
"How thin the line,
"between the will to
live, and the will to die.
"How about a hole?" she asks.
"A really deep hole, which
you put in a public place,
"for general use.
"In Manhattan, say, at the
corner of Seventieth and Fifth.
"A sign beside the hole
reads: 4:00 PM to 8:00 PM,
"Mondays, Wednesdays and
Fridays, suicide permitted.
"Just that.
"A sign.
"Why, surely people would jump
"who had hardly thought of it before."
As I said, it's not only
rational, sometimes,
but it's also very easy.
Now, this is a CARTA symposium.
And we want to understand how humans,
against all the odds, perhaps,
have, in the end, survived and prospered.
And it looks as though,
suicide might be a very significant drain
on the fitness of our ancestors.
Looks as though it might
have been a major downside
of their growing sufficiently clever,
to understand their own mortality.
The very sequence Ajit talked about.
It wouldn't have been bad,
because (stammers) dangerous,
because they feared death,
but because they were attracted to it.
But, surely, natural selection, then,
would've sorted this out long ago.
Why haven't humans evolved to
have better innate defenses
against suicide, built into their minds?
Well, of course, Ajit thinks they have.
When reality becomes too much to bear,
people simply deny it.
But, I confess, I don't see
this working as he says,
or, at least, not in these contexts.
I see no evidence that humans have evolved
to have any kind of natural immunity
to what I've called the lure of death.
To the contrary, I'm led
to think that in the past,
if not today, suicide might
have spread like measles,
in an unprotected population.
In fact, measles is a surprisingly,
alarmingly apposite analogy,
because the suicide meme
happens to be highly infectious.
It jumps from mind to mind,
resulting in the
well-documented phenomenon
of copycat suicides.
As Durkheim wrote, "Suicide
is very contagious.
"There is the well-known
story of the fifteen patients
"who hung themselves, in
swift succession, in 1772,
"from the same hook, in a
dark passage of the hospital."
Suicide contagion has been
dubbed the Werther effect,
after the hero of Goethe's novel,
The Sorrows of Young Werther.
In the novel, Werther kills himself,
after falling hopelessly in
love with a married woman.
Following its publication in 1774,
there were literally hundreds
of copycat deaths in Germany.
Recent researchers confirmed
just how strong the effect is.
Every time a celebrity
suicide is given exposure
in a newspaper, or TV,
the copycats follow.
It's estimated that
Marilyn Monroe's death,
in August 1962, was responsible
for 200 actual suicides,
within a month.
After a popular South Korean actress,
hung herself in 2008,
suicides jumped 66 percent
that month,
with young, hanging victims accounting
for the most of the increase.
But, 66 percent, that's nothing.
There are some parts of the world today,
where rates of suicide are ten
times the average elsewhere.
And this turned out to be,
largely to do, with copying.
Among these happy people,
on the island of Palawan,
in the Philippines, MacDonald's
research has documented
waves of suicides, spreading
through small villages.
The question becomes, then,
how prevalent was suicide
amongst our ancestors,
say, 50,000 years ago?
I don't think any paleoanthropologist
has ever thought to ask.
But, assuming humans, must by then,
have required an understanding of death,
we can be quite sure there were suicides.
And let's remember, times were harsh,
in the icy climate of central Europe.
There would've been plenty
to be unhappy about,
or think we shouldn't
allow the possibility
that there were, indeed,
recurrent plagues of egoistic suicide,
with rates topping anything we see today.
Well, if this is true,
if there were these plagues of suicide,
and I think it's a genuine,
scientific possibility,
what could, and did,
bring it under control?
Assuming humans have never
evolved adequate natural immunity
to suicide, antidote, whatever it was,
must have been cultural.
And here, I have to say,
the picture's complicated,
and not well-researched.
Apparently, some of the
cultural barriers to suicide
are, indeed, in plain view.
In historical times, religious authorities
have regularly issued
an athamus against it.
Medieval Christianity
decreed that self-murderers
would go to Hell.
Victims would not be given
a decent burial, but rather,
be buried at the crossroads, at night,
with a stake through the heart.
In many countries, attempted suicide
has also been made a crime,
under the common law.
In the United Kingdom,
attempted suicide was not
decriminalized, until 1961.
In the ten years, pre-1961,
there were 6,000 prosecutions,
5,400 attempted suicides were
filed guilty, and imprisoned,
or fined.
It was common practice
in the 1950s, in Britain,
to have a policeman,
sitting at the bedside,
of an unconscious patient,
in accident and emergency,
waiting to interview the patient,
when he, or she, revived.
There've also been attempts to
limit the spread of suicide,
the suicide meme, by
limiting exposure to it.
In Europe, after the
effect of Goethe's book
became apparent, was soon
banned in several countries.
In Germany, it was even forbidden to dress
like young Werther, in blue
coat, and yellow trousers.
In most countries today,
there are restrict press guidelines,
intended to play down
the reporting of suicide,
to keep it off the front page,
and to avoid sensational headlines.
So, we've had suicidal
acts being punished,
and information about them suppressed.
Do these measures actually work?
My guess, I think there's reason to think,
they actually, probably, do.
Or, at any rate, there's no
reason to think that they don't.
But, surely, more focused
methods ought to work as well.
In place of punishment, or censorship,
why not try to fight meme with meme?
Why not oppose a destructive mind virus,
with a redemptive one?
What should we tell people,
who want to kill themselves?
The English priest, Chad Varah,
founded the Samaritans, in 1954,
a group dedicated to
talking suicides down,
with words of reassurance.
The message, there is hope,
may seem to verge on the banal,
but, in fact, it's the
one message we can give
with confidence.
Research shows, that in
nine cases out of ten,
the hurt isn't going to last.
Here's Daniel Gilbert, who
actually quoted off of the book,
Stumbling on Happiness,
"Few of us can accurately gauge
"how we will feel tomorrow, or next week.
"We expect to feel devastated,
if our spouse leaves us,
"or if we get passed over
for a big promotion at work.
"But, when things like that do happen,
"it's soon, 'She never was right for me,'
"or, 'Actually, I needed more
free time for my family.'
"People mistakenly expect such blows
"to be much more devastating
than they turn out to be."
And since it's a pessimism bias,
we think things are
going to be really bad,
so bad, that we can do
nothing, but end our lives.
But, the message of this
research, I suppose,
is, don't jump now,
because it's not what your
future self would choose.
But, have we had to wait
for a Harvard psychologist
to tell us this?
No, thankfully not.
The message is implicit.
Perhaps, actually presumably,
for a good reason.
In much of the hand-me-down
wisdom of our old cultures,
in stories, and songs,
and proverbs, and so on.
And the good news for our species,
is that on the whole, with
too many dreadful exceptions,
hope can, and does, win out.
And I think that's what basically
has taken us out of the ice
ages, to where we are today.
Okay.
This is the closing talk of the symposium.
We've heard a lot today, about
what a bad thing death is.
We haven't actually heard much
about what a good thing life
is, which is, in the end,
of course, the whole point.
So, I'll finish with a
passage from George Borrow's
autobiographical novel, Lavengro,
which echoes some of the things
actually Sheldon was saying.
As Borrow tells it, he's
been reading Goethe,
and it's an autobiography,
I think he had been,
and he's toying with the idea of suicide.
He gets into conversation
with a Romany gypsy, Jasper,
who he's befriended on his travels.
I'll read a passage from the novel.
"'What is your opinion of death?' said I,
"as I sat down beside him.
"Jasper replies, 'Life is sweet, brother.
"'Who would wish to die?'
"'I would wish to die,'" says Borrow.
"'You talk like a fool,' says Jasper.
"'Wish to die, indeed.
"'There's night and day,
brother, both sweet things;
"'sun, moon, and stars,
brother, all sweet things.
"'There's the wind on the heath, brother;
"'if I could only feel that,
I would gladly live forever.'"
Well, this painting is, in fact,
called The Wind on the Heath.
And I think the good news,
is that we've all been there.
Well, thank you.
(crowd applauding)
(mid-tempo electronic music)